pencil is very very capable and when I
say that as a very good driver myself
yes when you're saying that isn't Fault
in Our Stars no they just said they were
scary you're an amazing driver but they
said they were scared of different
things now you could be an amazing
driver still be scared oh yeah I'm not
saying a bad driver I think there's a or
two German they sent me a rather driver
Edgar said he'd rather drive a John and
then Lily said she'd rather drive with
with hazel no one has any faith in baby
I have a lot of faith I'm just wondering
I wasn't in the car someone I would say
s o is a very very good driver and it's
it's impressive to see look when you
throw a 2,000 pound car into a sideways
drift or sideways and you'll spin and
keep it under control
but it's pretty fun it's really fun to
be in the backseat it's more fun than
I've done both but it's really going to
be in the backseat especially when you
trust the kid at the wheel how much fun
you guys had making this movie I mean
the chemistry palpable and a lot of fun
about having fun promoting yeah good
people everyone's going to know it was a
blast it's nice to be involved something
that you know it proud of but you had a
great time work with you've enjoyed work
with everybody on the film I didn't know
anybody really I'd met Jamie a couple
times and Kevin a couple times at award
show or whatever but we hadn't worked
with anybody before so you know Edgar
was a friend of mine but like you never
know what you go into it like a working
environment like what it's going to be
and then when it comes out and it's like
oh this is fun I'd look forward to going
to work I'm excited you guys have
nicknames in the movie had to remake
name each other what would what would
those be
will you be not a baby anymore-- couple
years older so probably like to call you
like adolescent toddler pods or driver's
pod for table the feeler for Todd be
short for me
the amazing the mahjongg um Quan Jam go
flip the script oh I got some was
already added was there any added
pressure because this has been Edgar's
baby for so long I mean this is
something he's been thinking about for a
long time and finally came to fruition
did you guys feel any kind of a
depression I mean no more than you
really want to be nobody sets out to
make a bad movie obviously nobody wants
to be bad in the movie and nobody wants
to be the person that's you know not
pulling their weight I felt pressure I
mean showing up like look at other names
on the on the list you know and I I knew
that nothing is guaranteed in this
business and you need to do a good job
and I was like I gotta show up and do a
really good job
you never know I mean like some you show
up a didn't do a good job
I'm replaceable you know like Jamie and
Kevin and John not as much but like I'm
just a kid she learned that you know
it's a lesson that best actors learn
wire to top of the call sheet that you
lose a responsibility there Ansel had
the majority the heavy lifting on the
film he was there almost every day had a
lot of lines had a lot of the action had
a lot of the stuff they had to do and
and you know that's what being number
one is and it's a it's an important
lesson to learn for young actors that
like it takes a village but it's a lot
of it is on you and he came through with
flying colors and he delivered a
wonderful performance and it was a
pleasure to work with and a pleasant guy
and it sounds a guide it was it was a
real pleasure to to be around you know
get that marry off so you can do you
yeah yeah